are you familiar with just the podcast
or have you seen any of my television no
I'm I'm a fan of yours since the end of
the 90s oh wow okay well I started in
the early 90s so oh come on I guess
there was a couple years there where you
weren't into it it lives in Argentina
okay so how did you come to know the
show I I traveled to the US and I
watched the show and I really liked how
I mean how silly you were and how silly
everybody was awesome everything so
after that I
well I I obtained the episodes what what
is that what does that mean yeah you
know no I don't know
why don't you tell me what it doesn't
play here in Argentina so I went to the
interwebs and obtained the the episodes
you've pirated my TV show we got you
this is the ski yeah we got you we got
you now that's the only reason I'm
talking to you is that we got a red
alert yep coming from a province in
Argentina that someone was watching the
old shows oh so you would uh you you
pirated the TV show but I don't care I'm
glad you were just watching and as long
as you pay me what you owe me we're
we're good you have to look it like this
I love the show and you enough to commit
the felony yeah
and she was a lawyer yeah yeah and you
gotten disbarred right in fact I think
you subconsciously wanted to get
disbarred so you could start your yoga
career well I'm very happy that you uh
watch those old shows and that they
brought you some Joy that's that's why
we did them so I'm glad that you I also
went to to see you in person once in
Burbank how was it and it was amazing it
was Christoph Waltz was the the the the
guest oh I love Christoph Waltz yeah
he's terrific yeah he's so I I he has he
had recently won an Oscar so it was a
big night and and I was happy to meet uh
to get to know oh everybody I I think
sauna gave me the ticket something like
that oh wow incredible so you even got
to know Sona did you enjoy when I walked
out and you saw me in person uh you'd
only see me on TV before but when you
saw me in person what did you think he's
so tall
yes what did you want her to say yeah
what did you want I wanted you to say
that uh his there was a light coming
from his face that felt like Christ had
come back to earth oh is that too much
there's a reflection coming from his
face yeah so you noticed that I was tall
yeah yeah that's that's very impressive
to me I'm told too so it's that's really
impressive to me if you were short that
would have been something like oh my God
he's a key chain yeah I'm going to tell
you something a lot of comedians in my
business are very short uh I'm the tall
one so just keep that in mind
why should she keep that in mind I just
don't like anybody else just just stay
focused on Conan he's the tall one what
yeah you want her to just remember
you're tall so she can continue liking
you everything you just said makes
perfect sense to me oh man